hello everyone welcome to the first
screencast in our series on presenting
your research the purpose of this series
is really to help you do outstanding
scholarship in the field of nlp and i'm
also going to try to demystify
publishing in the field of nlp
to kick it off i'd like to focus on the
final papers that you're writing
specifically for this course
um here are some practical details these
links take you to essential things about
writing final paper specifically for
cs224u the first link is possibly the
most important that just enumerates the
requirements for the final paper please
do review it to make sure that you don't
get points off or something small that
could easily have been corrected just
because you didn't conform to our
requirements
the next two links are much more about
helping you with the substance of this
so the projects file has lots of
frequently asked questions and other
information about writing final papers
for this course and it also expands out
to publishing in the field of nlp so it
has a lot of useful resources when it
comes to trying to report out your
research to the community
and then this third link here links to
some excellent past final projects many
of them became publications typically
after a bunch of additional work after
the end of the quarter but it is
exciting that a lot of these really
excellent published papers began in this
course it's very inspiring
for your projects i just want to review
a really important point for me that
concerns how we'll evaluate your work
this is from the methods unit for the
course but i want to repeat it here just
to emphasize it
we will never evaluate a project based
on how good the results are
we do recognize that in our field as in
all scientific fields publications tend
to do this because they have additional
constraints on space and that leads them
as a cultural fact to favor positive
evidence for new developments over
negative results but we of course are
not subject to such constraints so we
can do the right and good things
scientifically evaluating positive
results negative results and everything
in between
this has real consequences for how we do
evaluation right we're going to evaluate
your project based on the
appropriateness of the metrics that you
chose the strength of the methods that
you used and maybe most important
importantly the extent to which your
paper is open and clear-sighted about
the limitations of its finding
those are the things that really matter
for us scientifically and it is a
consequence of this policy that you
could have a paper that reported
state-of-the-art results but if it's
just not a clear and substantive paper
it might not get very good marks from us
and conversely if all of your hypotheses
fell apart and it turned out that all
your evidence pointed away from them as
being true but you nonetheless wrote a
paper that was clear about those
findings and helped push the field
forward by steering us away from those
hypotheses that of course could earn top
marks and we'd be very happy to help you
report those results out to the rest of
the field because it is important for us
to know about these negative findings so
that we know where to invest our energy
as scholars
here's a detail that's um from the
requirements for the final paper this is
the authorship statement
um this is just a section where you
explain how the individual authors from
your team and anyone else who helped out
contributed to the final project
you're free to say whatever you like in
these sections if you would like a model
here's a link to the pnas guidelines
which gives some details of kind of
typical statements
the rationale is really just that we
think this is an important aspect of
scholarship in general and it's not yet
pervasive in the field of nlp whereas it
is in other fields but we would like it
to be more widespread because it just
seems like a healthy form of disclosure
that's the real rationale i want to
emphasize that only in really extreme
cases and after discussion with all the
team members would we consider giving
separate grades to the team
based on what was in this statement this
is really not the intent
the intent rather is this rationale of
just disclosing who did what as part of
the project it's really not about
evaluation
i also want to emphasize that we have a
policy on multiple submissions for this
course it's nuanced and subjective
here's a link to it
uh here and here are some notes kind of
rational for this so first the policy
mirrors the policy on multiple
submission to conferences right you
can't take the same paper and submit it
to two different venues with minor
modifications and expect to get two
publications out of it and the same
thing holds for us when we think about
requirements for final papers for this
course
this is designed to ensure that your
project is a substantial new effort
this does mean that you can't merely
submit an incremental advancement over
another project that you did we are
trying to push back against the pattern
where people would take final projects
from previous courses add a couple of
new models and submit those as entirely
new papers that's just unfair to the
people who are starting from scratch and
it's really not the sort of work that we
would say is up to the level of a final
project for a course like this
this other courses might have different
policies at stanford but that fact alone
is not going to lead us to change our
policy because we do think that this is
equitable and also reflecting values
that are pervasive in our field as you
can see from the policies on submission
to conferences
if any of these policies seem relevant
to your work for example if you are
taking a previous course project and
developing it in lots of fresh and new
ways start the discussion with your
mentor as early as possible to make sure
that they're in the loop about what
you're doing
we don't want any surprises when you
submit your final paper or after that
when it comes to this policy so just
make sure everyone is in the know and i
predict that things will go fine
to close a brief note about impact
statements for now an impact statement
is an optional section for your final
paper absolutely not required but this
has been on my mind a lot lately i think
it's really healthy that the field is
moving toward having authors include
impact statements and so i thought i
would exhort you all to consider having
that as part of your final paper as well
it does not count against your length
limits and it's up to you exactly what
you would disclose as part of this
statement there are some examples of
things that you might include you could
try to enumerate both the benefits and
the risks of your research to
individuals to society to the world
specifically for the risk you could talk
about costs again to the participants to
society to the planet where for example
participant costs would be if you had
human annotators doing a really
difficult
or kind of negative annotation project
you might mention that they paid a
certain cost and think about whether the
costs were worthwhile you could also
think about cost to society and that
would really probably turn on sort of
misapplication of your ideas in ways
that might have more harm than good and
of course if you trained a really large
language model or did a really a lot of
experiments you could think about the
cost to the planet in terms of energy
expenditures and so forth
just by way of getting us all to think
about the fact that our research does
have costs and that we should all the
time be thinking about the cost benefit
analysis when it comes to the work that
we do
and these disclosures are part of
helping us all have that in mind
and finally i think it might be really
inspiring for you to think about
responsibly use of your data models and
findings never mind really evil actors
there are likely to be people out there
who are well-meaning and would like to
apply your ideas but they might be
unsure of the limits per se unsure of
precisely how to do that responsibly so
guidance that you could offer about
where your ideas work and where they
don't or where your data are relevant
and where they're irrelevant could
really help someone who is trying to
just make responsible use of your ideas
you could think about them as part of
crafting this impact statement
for other resources you know i think
it's really great to go through the
exercise of doing a data sheet and a
model card a data sheet is a disclosure
about a data set that you created or
used and a model card is a similar sort
of structured document for models that
you develop and release out into the
world
they're both pretty long documents so
it's a lot of work to do one in full but
it's very rewarding in the sense that it
helps you confront some hard truths
about the work that you did and
articulate the limits of the work that
you did all these things are really
helpful for your scholarship
and of course these things are helpful
when it comes to other people consuming
your ideas so that's highly encouraged
and you could take bits and pieces from
those structured documents and have them
inform maybe a shorter impact statement
that you wrote
and for even more guidance on this you
could check out this survey of nurip's
impact statements it has a lot of
information about the kinds of things
people are disclosing in these
statements and that too could help you
kind of figure out what you want to say
and what might be relevant to your
audience
so again this is entirely optional but i
hope this is inspiring and interesting
for you as a new dimension
when it comes to reporting on the work
that you did